I'm going to speak to you about the
global refugee crisis and my aim is to
show you that this crisis is manageable
not unsolvable but also show you that
this is as much about us and who we are
as it is a trial of the refugees on the
frontline for me this is not just a
professional obligation because I run an
NGO supporting refugees and displaced
people around the world
it's personal I love this picture that
really handsome guy on the right that's
not me that's my dad Ralph in London in
1940 with his father Samuel they were
Jewish refugees from Belgium they fled
the day the Nazis invaded and I love
this picture too it's a group of refugee
children arriving in England in 1946
from Poland and in the middle is my
mother Miriam she was sent to start a
new life in a new country on her own at
the age of 12 I know this if Britain had
not admitted refugees in the 1940s I
certainly would not be here today
yet 70 years on the wheel has come full
circle the sound is of wolves being
built
vengeful political rhetoric humanitarian
values and principles on fire in the
very countries at 70 years ago said
never again to statelessness and
hopelessness for the victims of war last
year every minute 24 more people were
displaced from their homes by conflict
violence and persecution another
chemical weapon attack
in Syria the Taliban on the rampage in
Afghanistan girls driven from their
school in Northeast Nigeria by Boko
Haram these are not people moving to
another country to get a better life
they're fleeing for their lives it's a
real tragedy that the world's most
famous refugee can't come to speak to
you here today many of you will know
this picture it shows the lifeless body
of five year old Alan Kurdi a Syrian
refugee who died in the Mediterranean in
2015 he died alongside 3700 others
trying to get to Europe the next year
2016 five thousand people died it's too
late for them but it's not too late for
millions of others it's not too late for
people like Fredrik I met him in the
near guro Sioux refugee camp in Tanzania
he's from Burundi he wanted to know
where could he complete his studies he'd
done 11 years of schooling he wanted a
12 yeah he said to me I pray that my
days did not end here in this refugee
camp and it's not too late for her lude
her parents were Palestinian refugees
living in the Yarmouk refugee camp
outside Damascus she was born to refugee
parents and now she's a refugee herself
in Lebanon she's working for the
International Rescue Committee to help
other refugees but she has no certainty
at all about her future where it is or
what it holds this talk is about
Frederic about her lewd and about
millions like them why they're displaced
how they survived what help they need
and what our responsibilities are I
truly believe this that the biggest
question in the 21st century concerns
our duty to strangers the future you is
about your duties to strangers
you know better than anyone the world is
more connected than ever before yet the
great danger is that we're consumed by
our divisions and there is no better
test of that than how we treat refugees
here are the facts 65 million people
displaced from their homes by violence
and persecution last year if it was a
country that would be the 21st largest
country in the world most of those
people about 40 million stay within
their own home country but 25 million
are refugees that means they cross a
border into a neighboring state most of
them are living in poor countries
relatively poor lower middle income
countries like Lebanon where her lude is
living in Lebanon one in four people is
a refugee a quarter of the whole
population and refugees stay for a long
time the average length of displacement
is ten years I went to the what was the
world's largest refugee camp in eastern
Kenya it's called Dadaab it was built in
1991-92 as a quote unquote temporary
camp for Somalis fleeing the Civil War
I met silo and naively I said to silo do
you think you'll ever go home to Somalia
and she said what do you mean go home I
was born here and then when I asked the
camp management how many of the 330
thousand people in that camp were born
there they gave me the answer 100,000
that's what long-term displacement means
now the causes of this are deep weak
states that can't support their own
people an international political system
weaker than at any time since 1945 and
differences over theology government's
engagement with the outside world in
significant parts of the Muslim world
now those are long-term generational
challenges that's why I say that this
refugee crisis is a trend and not a blip
and it's complex and when you have big
large
long-term complex problems people think
nothing can be done when Pope Francis
went to land producer off the coast of
Italy in 2014 he accused all of us and
the global population of what he called
the globalization of indifference it's a
haunting phrase it means that our hearts
have turned to stone now I don't know
you tell me are you allowed to argue
with the Pope even even as a TED
Conference but I think it's not right I
think people do want to make a
difference but they just don't know
whether there are any solutions to this
crisis and what I want to tell you today
is that though the problems are real the
solutions are real - solution one these
refugees need to get into work in the
countries where they're living and the
countries where they're living need
massive economic support in Uganda in
2014 they did a study 80% of refugees in
the capital city Kampala needed no
humanitarian aid because they were
working they were supported in to work
solution number two education for kids
is a lifeline not a luxury when you're
displaced for so long kids can bounce
back when they're given the proper
social emotional support alongside
literacy and numeracy I've seen it for
myself
but half of the world's refugee children
of primary school age get no education
at all
and three-quarters of secondary school
age get no education at all that's crazy
solution number three most refugees are
in urban areas city is not in camps what
would you or I want if we were in a
refugee and a city wouldn't want money
to pay rent or buy clothes that is the
future of the humanitarian system or a
significant part of it give people cash
so that you boost the power of refugees
and actually you'll help the local
economy and as a fourth solution to
that's controversial but needs to be
talked about the most vulnerable
refugees need to be given a new start
and a new life in a new country
including in the West the numbers are
relatively small hundreds of thousands
not millions but the symbolism is huge
now it's not the time to be banning
refugees as the Trump administration
proposed it's a time to be embracing
people who are victims of terror and
remember remember anyone who asks you
are they properly vetted that's a really
sensible and good question to ask
the truth is refugees arriving for
resettlement are more vetted than any
other population arriving in our
countries so while it's reasonable to
ask the question it's not reasonable to
say that refugee is another word for
terrorists now what happens what happens
when refugees can't get work they can't
get their kids into school they can't
get cash they can't get a legal route to
hope what happens is they take risky
journeys I went to lesbos this beautiful
Greek island two years ago it's a home
to 90,000 people in one year 500,000
refugees went across the island and I
want to show you what I saw when I drove
across to the north of the island a pile
of lifejackets of those who'd made it to
shore and when I look closer there were
small life jackets for children yellow
ones and I took this picture you
probably can't see the writing but I
want to read it for you
warning will not protect against
drowning so in the 21st century children
are being given life jackets to reach
safety in Europe even though those
jackets will not save their lives if
they fall out of the boats that is
taking them that this is not just a
crisis it's a test it's a test that
civilizations have faced down the ages
it's a test of our humanity it's a test
of us in the Western world of who we are
and what we stand for it's a test of our
character not just our policies and
refugees are a hard case they do come
from far away parts of the world
they have been through trauma there
often of a different religion those are
precisely the reasons we should be
helping refugees not a reason not to
help them and it's a reason to help them
because of what it says about us it's
revealing of our values empathy and
altruism are two of the foundations of
civilization turn that empathy and
altruism into action and we live out a
basic moral credo and in the modern
world we have no excuse we can't say we
don't know what's happening in Juba
South Sudan or Aleppo Syria it's there
in our smartphone in our hand
ignorance is no excuse at all fail to
help and we show we have no moral
compass at all it's also revealing about
whether we know our own history the
reason that refugees have rights around
the world is because of extraordinary
Western leadership by States men and
women after the second world war that
became universal rights trash the
protections of refugees and we trash our
own history this is this is also
revealing about the power of democracy
as a refuge from dictatorship how many
politicians have you heard say we
believe in the power of our example not
the example of our power what they mean
is what we stand for is more important
than the bombs we drop refugees seeking
sanctuary and seen the West as a source
of hope and a place of Haven Russians
Iranians Chinese eretrians Cubans
they've come to the West for safety we
throw that away at our peril
and there's one other thing it reveals
about us our whether we have any
humility for our own mistakes I'm not
one of these people who believes that
all the problems in the world are caused
by the West they're not but when we make
mistakes we should recognize him it's
not an accident that the country which
has taken more refugees than the other
the United States has taken more
refugees from Vietnam than any other
country
it speaks to the history but there's
more recent history in Iraq in
Afghanistan you can't make up for
foreign policy errors by humanitarian
action but when you break something you
have a duty to try to help repair it and
that's our duty now to remember at the
beginning of the tool I said I wanted to
explain that the refugee crisis was
manageable not insoluble that's true I
want you to think in a new way
I also want you to do things if you're
an employer hire refugees if you're
persuaded by the arguments take on the
myths when family or friends or
workmates repeat them if you've got
money give it to charities that make a
difference for refugees around the world
if you're a citizen vote for politicians
who will put into practice the solutions
that I talked about the duty to
strangers shows itself in small ways and
big prosaic and heroic in 1942 my arm
and my grandmother were living in
Brussels under German occupation they
received a summons from the Nazi
authorities to go to Brussels railway
station
my grandmother immediately thought
something was amiss she pleaded with her
relatives not to go to Brussels railway
station her relatives said to her if we
don't go if we don't do what we're told
then we're going to be in trouble you
can guess what happened to the relatives
who went to Brussels railway station
they were never seen again
but my grandmother in my arms they went
to a small village south of Brussels
where they'd been on holiday in the
decade before and they presented
themselves at the house of the local
farmer a Catholic farmer called Monsieur
Maurice
and they asked him to take them in and
he did and by the end of the war 17 Jews
I was told were living in that village
and when I was a teenager I asked my arm
can you take me to meet Monsieur Maurice
and she said yeah I can he's he's still
alive let's go and see him and so when I
must be in 83 84 we went to see him and
I suppose like a only a teenager could
when I met him he was this white-haired
gentleman I said to him why did you do
it why did you take that risk and he
looked at me and he shrugged me said in
French on Bois one must it was innate in
him it was natural and my point to you
is it should be a natural and innate in
us to tell yourself this refugee crisis
is manageable not unsolvable and each
one of us has a personal responsibility
to help make itself because this is
about the rescue of us and our values as
well as the rescue of refugees and their
lives thank you very much indeed
[Music]
Simon
maybe thank you thank you
those are strong suggestions and your
call for individual responsibilities is
very strong as well but I'm troubled by
one thought and is this
you mentioned and these are your words
extraordinary Western leadership which
led 60 something years ago to the world
discussion about human rights to the
conventions of refugees etc etc just
leadership happened after a big trauma
and happened in a consensual political
space and now we are in a divisive for
it especially refugees has become one of
the divisive issues so where will
leadership come from today well I think
that you're right to say that the
leadership forged in war has a different
temper and a different tempo and a
different outlook than leadership forged
in peace and so my answer would be the
leadership has got to come from below
not from above I mean that's the
recurring theme of the conference this
week has been about the democratization
of power and we've got to preserve our
own democracies but we've got to also
activate our own democracies and when
people say to me there's a backlash
against refugees what I say to them is
no there's a polarization and at the
moment those who are fearful are making
more noise than those who are proud and
so my answer to your question is that we
will sponsor and encourage and give
confidence to leadership when we
mobilize ourselves and I think that when
you are in a position of looking for
leadership you have to look inside and
mobilize in your own community to try to
create the conditions for a different
kind of settlement
thank you David thanks for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you